[Musica]
non voglio certo oggi spiegarvi perché
sono importanti i feedback
lo hanno spiegato bene gli speaker di
prima che ci hanno parlato di feedback
che arrivano dall universo più remoto e
feedback che arrivano da il nutrimento
attraverso il gusto
oggi io sono qui per fare delle domande
è la domanda che a me piace fare sempre
è sull'archetipo cioè su le cose più
antiche della nostra esistenza e per
mettermi in fib con voi vi faccio questa
domanda qual è stato il vostro primo
feedback in termini di ricordo e logico
che non posso stare qui a sentire tutti
i vostri feedback
ma fortunatamente ho utilizzato la rete
che è uno strumento fantastico per
ottenere feedback cercando e chiedendo
ai miei diciamo amici di darmi i loro
feedback
la maggior parte delle persone mi ha
dato dei feedback legati a la loro
nascita e nello specifico il loro
rapporto con la madre
nell'atto di allattare non a caso nella
parola feed back c'è una parolina che la
compone iniziale che appunto field è la
traduzione letterale e appunto nutrire
quindi nutrire e ricevere qualcosa in
cambio
ricevere qualcosa in cambio non solo in
termini materiali ma anche in termini
immateriali quindi la nascita è in
qualche maniera la condivisione di un
informazione e nello specifico
dell'informazione più preziosa che noi
abbiamo che è il nostro dna
noi mettiamo in sharing il dna con un
altro
creiamo una nuova vita e quella vita è
una memoria che contiene i feedback che
arrivano dall uomo del passato il dna
appunto almeno io amo definirlo a vari
layer il layer quelli diciamo principali
sono layer e che danno a noi il colore
degli occhi che ci dicono che i capelli
avremo ma alcuni scienziati stanno
scoprendo un po come un piccolo universo
che all'interno del dna ci sono
tantissime altre informazioni e queste
informazioni hanno a che vedere con i
processi che l'uomo ha imparato nel
corso della storia cioè i feedback
il dna è un feedback è qualcosa che
permette di conservare la specie ma che
permette soprattutto di conservare i
processi che l'uomo accumulato nel tempo
tutti sappiamo anzi diciamo sempre
ultimi studi hanno dimostrato come il
dna nella nostra vita si modifica in
funzione di questi feedback quindi
studiare quindi praticare dello sport
quindi avere interazioni sociali
permette di inserire nuovi tasselli e di
programmare questi nuovi tasselli
all'interno del nostro dna
quindi come dire i feedback in tal senso
sono appunto molto molto importanti
ogni tanto con i miei allievi e perché
io ho la fortuna di insegnare quindi ho
la fortuna di imparare molte cose faccio
che cosa faccio questa assonanza tra
riproduzione umana e riproduzione dei
processi e mi piace sempre scherzando
dire che sto in seminando un po i miei
allievi già sto inserendo delle piccole
parti del mio dna dei processi del mio
dna all'interno dei miei allievi quindi
sto in qualche maniera
portando avanti la mia genetica
processuale in altre persone proprio
esattamente come la nascita
prendiamo la dicitura da garzanti di
feedback feedback in garzanti viene
definito come un immissione retroattiva
come un nutrire caricare all'indietro ma
è definito anche come un effetto di
reazione prodotto da un messaggio su chi
o cosa lo ha emesso e proprio per questo
voglio farvi una piccola storia delle
interazioni umane
l'uomo comincia appunto pre nascita a
utilizzare il tatto per comunicare solo
che il feedback è 1 a 1 1 1 con la madre
poi esce
sfortunatamente ci sono anche i padri
che giocano con i figli e quindi
cominciano a toccarsi anche padre e
figlio
a un certo punto il figlio comincia a
parlare e quindi ha sempre più ha
bisogno di feedback sempre maggiori io
sono qui sto parlando con voi perché
voglio avere feedback e ho la
possibilità attraverso la parola di
aumentare i peer come vengono chiamati
in termini social
a un certo punto gli assiro babilonesi
decidono che quella parola può essere
scritta e con gutenberg noi possiamo e
abbiamo feedback che arrivano dal
passato perché sono stati fissati e
quindi non sono stati solo lanciati o
comunque condivisi per via orale ma
soprattutto oggi noi abbiamo che cosa
abbiamo una cosa meravigliosa che è
internet
internet è il luogo dei feedback è il
luogo del che massimizza i feedback è
stata una necessità dell'uomo quella di
creare i feedback
proprio per questo voglio raccontarvi un
aneddoto che ho rubato a un
a un amico lui racconta sempre di
ritorno al futuro con avete visto tutti
il ritorno al futuro nessuno può dire di
no ritorno al futuro ha previsto un po
di cose ha previsto l'over board ce
l'abbiamo
online è pieno di overboard su youtube
che viaggiano ha previsto le scarpe che
si allacciano da sole ha previsto il
viaggio nel tempo l'attenzione che è
stephen hopkins ha scritto un bellissimo
trattato che si chiama viaggio nel tempo
out bild e time machine
ok quindi sta cercando come dire ha
scritto già come si può fare il problema
che ci vuole un sacco di energia per
riuscire a viaggi nei vari viaggi nel
tempo però speriamo di poterci arrivare
ma cosa non ha previsto internet
internet attenzione che è del 1982
ritorno al futuro nel 1983 internet esce
quindi da arpanet diventa internet e ha
creato una piccola singolarità cioè ha
messo in connessione il mondo e quindi
ha messo in connessione la conoscenza
internet apre scenari che prima non si
potevano immaginare cioè apre un futuro
che non poteva essere scritto prima a me
ogni tanto piace fare una cosa si chiama
in vision in realtà per spiegare che
cos'è la in vision in uso una frase mi
piace fare archeologia del futuro mi
piace disegnare degli scenari
io adesso vorrei disegnare bene uno e
questo scenario si avvicina molto a
quella che è la mia idea di paradiso un
mondo super connesso che grazie alle
super connessioni grazie alla velocità
che la tecnologia sta avendo quindi ai
supercomputer sempre più veloci e grazie
all'intelligenza artificiale ci sta
portando verso un mondo migliore un
mondo fatto di cura di malattie perché
perché si posi noi attraverso
l'immaterialità della simulazione
possiamo simulare cose che prima
dovevamo sperimentare e quindi ci
permette di avere uno strumento
velocissimo che ci permette di
velocizzare appunto il progresso verso
uno scenario meraviglioso
a proposito di paradiso
quando hanno chiesto a san paolo
filosofo teologo e gli hanno chiesto
perché dopo la morte di cristo non siamo
arrivati non siamo tornati nel paradiso
e lui non sapendo come rispondere subito
ha detto questa frase in greco che è
toccate con toccate con vuol dire colui
che resiste l'uomo o meglio lui parlava
di romagna di ebrei
però diciamo l'uomo può esser visto come
un resistore può essere visto come
qualcosa che resiste la resistenza porta
al conflitto
la resistenza porta agli scenari che la
fiction ci fa vedere spesso della
tecnologia ci fa vedere black mirror ci
fa vedere matrix
ok ci fa vedere degli scenari che ci
fanno paura
il mio invito è invece a non aver paura
della tecnologia di non aver paura dei
feedback e generati dalla tecnologia
perché questi ci porteranno appunto in
un futuro migliore
non è un errore tecnico
tranquilli questa cosa qui tornando a
ritorno al futuro è una chitarra
elettrica in larsen mi ritorno al futuro
il nostro mcfly fa un concerto a un
certo punto comincia a mandare la
chitarra e la fa fischiare
che cos'è un larsen come vi dicevo prima
io voglio cercare di portarvi a capire
qual è l'archetipo del feedback e per
farlo ho bisogno di appunto spiegarvi
che cos'è un
audio un feedback audio è un prodotto da
che cosa sa che cosa ha bisogno ha
bisogno di un input e un output
qualsiasi sistema di feedback ha bisogno
di in and out senza in e out
io non ho feedback ok c'è dell'area ok
delle particelle d'aria di gas che cosa
fanno queste particelle d'aria a un
certo punto succede una cosa magica una
dimensione che è quella dello spazio
attraverso il sistema elettroacustico
viene annullata
cioè si annulla una dimensione e cosa
succede a chi ci becca due
caratteristiche fantastiche
una è quella di ordinare le cose e per
quello che noi sentiamo un fischio quel
fischio è una sinusoide prodotta appunto
dal feedback di uno speaker con un
microfono
volevo farlo anche qui prendere un
microfono a metterlo vicino allo speaker
per farvelo sentire suonare ma mi sa che
ne avete esperienza soprattutto quando
ci sono i tecnici non bravi ai concerti
quindi cosa succede la caratteristica è
quella di riuscire a ordinare le cose
mettere in ordine le cose ma soprattutto
di creare cose che prima non esistevano
e proprio per questo vi volevo fare un
diciamo un esempio l'esempio è un
paradosso
facciamo finta che la dimensione non sia
lo spazio ma si sa il tempo e quindi
tornando a ritorno al futuro io potessi
oggi viaggiare nel tempo e tornare
esattamente a 11 minuti fa quanti davide
ci sarebbero due e se dopo 11 minuti
quei 2 davide tornassero indietro nel
tempo
quanti davide ci sarebbero 4 cioè il
feedback temporale
nello specifico a questa proprietà ha
una proprietà di creare cose che non
esistono
o meglio di moltiplicare cose che non
esistevano
prima ci hanno parlato di big bang
io ho un ipotesi volevo condividerlo
potrebbe il bing bang essere appunto una
singolarità data dal fatto che in quel
momento due o più dimensioni siano
collassate su se stesse e quindi quello
scoppio di creazione sia avvenuto
proprio attraverso un feedback
primordiale mi piace parlare di
archetipi e di primitive
facciamo un salto ai fotoni che è la
parte più immateriale della nostra
esistenza il fotone proprio perché
viaggia alla velocità della luce non a
massa mio figlio quando ero piccolo e
parlavo di appunto di immateriale mi ha
chiesto papà ma perché qui che cosa vuol
dire in materiale e io gli ho detto a
quella cosa che puoi vedere ma non puoi
toccare e lui a tre anni mi ha risposto
la luce papa semplice la luce è quella
cosa appunto che non a massa viaggia
alla velocità della luce e quindi lei si
trova nel tutto lei contiene il tutto è
in un feedback temporale ed è per quello
forse che oscilla perché è sempre nello
stesso istante ed è per quello che poi è
energia
però non voglio entrare in questi queste
tematiche sono dovrei fare altri quattro
top su questo
un'altra singolarità che diciamo
l'universo ci riserva è il buco nero
primo ne abbiamo sentito parlare
il buco nero ha una caratteristica
quella di collassare molta massa e ha la
caratteristica di collassando molta
massa di piegare lo spazio tempo una
delle ipotesi dei buchi neri è che
questi siano dei portali per collegare
parti molto lontane dell'universo un po
e un po come il feedback audio che
abbiamo sentito e visto prima
ci sono due posti nell'universo e c'è
una dimensione che è quella dello spazio
che collassa e quindi mi permette di
fare un viaggio molto lontano
stiamo parlando di materiale cos'è più
immateriale di un beat di una
allocazione di memoria all'interno di un
computer che descrive uno stato binario
di informazione detta grossa cerco di
spiegarvi perché il digitale per me si
rifà sempre a questo archetipo del
feedback perché nel digitale esiste
qualcosa che si che viene chiamata ciclo
for digitale arriva dalla macchina la
macchina arriva dalle macchine di
calcolo da pascal passando per touring
per arrivare ai moderni calcolatori che
prendono quei processi che sono in
feedback sono delle ruote che girano e
li mette dentro un algoritmo questo è
una cosa che in informatica
io ho messo davide potevo mettere pippo
come potevano mettere paperino o sergio
non c'è differenza in informatica una
variabile deve essere chiamata e quando
io la chiamo magicamente il computer
mette in memoria una allocazione e la
tiene buona per davide cioè per pippo
oppure per questa variabile noi leggiamo
sempre da sinistra verso destra il
computer invece legge al contrario cioè
davide è uguale a da anzi davide più uno
è uguale a davide per essere corretti
per leggere bene cosa succede quando
davide più uno è uguale a e davide e io
lo metto nei computer i computers in ne
fa di tutte fa una cosa che si chiama
stack overflow cioè io non posso auto
definirmi non posso dire che david e
davide più uno come o 6 davide o sei
gravi le più uno infatti la cosa bella
dei processi digitali e nello specifico
del feedback del ciclo forum è che c'è
questa cosa magica che si chiama
keystone il ciclo cioè il campionamento
il computer non fa le cose
le cose assieme ne fa una alla volta
molto velocemente ma una alla volta
quel ciclo mi permette di fare in modo
che il ciclo dopo quella variabile che
si chiamava david è diventet da vede più
uno questo è in informatica quello che
viene chiamato counter contatore conta
il computer conta oggi ma soprattutto è
il feedback cioè il ciclo dopo davide
più uno che è diventato uno perché
davide re uguale a zero diventa 2 poi
diventa 3 poi diventa 4 poi diventa 5
finché non c'è un'altra istruzione che
azzera davide social design interaction
design internet delle cose
stiamo parlando di digitale come vi
dicevo prima davide io sono un
appassionato di interazioni e sono un
appassionato di quella cosa che sta al
centro che si chiama interaction design
cioè interazione uomo macchina
il social design è l'interazione tra
uomo e uomo
l'internet delle cose è l'interazione
tra macchina e macchina se noi
consideriamo che l'uomo è una macchina
molto diciamo precisa e perfetta molto
quindi se mettiamo sullo stesso piano
macchina e uomo vediamo che le tre le
differenze tra queste tre aree vanno a
scemare
voglio concludere con una frase la frase
è questa
anzi un invito mio invito essere
responsabili dei propri feedback perché
soprattutto dei feedback e delle nostre
interazioni
che queste connessioni sottili e
immateriali c permeano terme nella
nostra esistenza
ma soprattutto ci connettono col futuro
che ci aspetta
grazie
[Applauso]